Tag 4 auf der Haute Route,
der berühmtesten Skitour
von Chamonix nach Zermatt.
Die besseren Skifahrer
können das Couloir hinunterfahren.
Paul und Peter
können das Fixseil zur Hilfe nehmen,
um hinunter zu fahren.
Wieder ein Steilhang - fast 45°.
Fränzi Aufdenblatten
und Dominique Gisin,
die beiden ehemaligen Skirenn-
fahrerinnen wagen die Abfahrt.
Ein Seil muss es
für die andern richten,
ein Sturz hätte fatale Folgen.
* Dramatische Klänge *
Die Gruppe ist heute seit
bereits 6 Std. unterwegs.
Es ist Mittag und heiss,
vor ihnen liegt der gefürchtete,
lange Abschnitt
entlang des Lac des Dix.
Ich hoffe, dass es dort vorne
noch etwas runter geht.
Und wo gehen wir lang?
Folgen wir der Spur?
Genau, wir folgen der Spur.
Die Abfahrten sind schon gut,
das stimmt für mich.
Deswegen gehe ich auf Skitouren,
dass ich runterfahren kann.
Aber der Schnee
ist jetzt nicht mehr so schön.
Das ist schade.
Aber so ist das eben im Frühling.
Der vierte Tag,
der härteste und längste der Tour.
Es wird warm und es geht über ein
sehr langes Flachstück nach hinten.
Gewarnt wurde die Gruppe bereits
am Vortag von Bergführer David Fasel.
Dem See entlang, ja.
80 km, 7'000 Höhenmeter in sechs
Tagen: Das ist die Haute Route.
Ein Pensionär, ein Heilpädagoge,
eine kaufmännische Angestellte,
zwei Skirennfahrerinnen,
ein CEO und eine Haushaltslehrerin
wollen sich diesen Traum erfüllen.
Gestartet sind sie heute
um 5 Uhr in der Cabane Montfort.
Nach 5 Std.
erreichten sie die Rosablanche.
Und nun befinden sie sich
in der langen Fläche
entlang des Lac des Dix,
vor dem Aufstieg zur Cabane des Dix.
Eine Etappe von 9 Stunden, 17 km, mit
1'800 m Aufstieg in grosser Hitze.
Severin, CEO der Allianzgruppe Swiss,
zieht mit Olympiasiegerin
Dominique Gisin vorne weg,
gefolgt von Peter,
dem Heilpädagogen aus Zürich.
Es ist heiss.
Und ich habe schon
einen langen Tag in den Knochen,
aber es geht.
Bergführer David Fasel
drängt aufs Tempo.
Wenn man einen umgekehrten Stock
einfach so
in den Nassschnee stecken kann,
dann ist man schon zu spät dran.
Aber jetzt sind wir
hier auf der Fläche,
da spielt es nicht so eine Rolle.
Bei einer Hangfahrt hingegen
müssten wir das beachten.
Jetzt gehen wir
über dieses Flachstück,
das uns zum Nordhang führt,
wo das nicht so ein Problem ist.
Und oben ist es wieder flach
bis zur Hütte.
Aber wir müssen etwas Gas geben.
Etwas später - und wir dürften
nicht mehr dort entlang fahren.
Ja, es war ein harter Winter.
Ich habe gehört, dass es letztes
Jahr in den Schweizer Alpen,
ich will jetzt nichts behaupten,
fast 30 Tote gegeben habe.
Aber zum Teil haben sich die Leute
auch fahrlässig verhalten.
Die Natur, das Wetter, sie können
über Leben und Tod entscheiden,
wie sich auch auf der Haute Route
einige Tage später zeigen wird.
Die Gruppe
hat sich inzwischen getrennt.
David wählt mit Severin, Fränzi,
Dominique, Yolanda und Peter
die Strecke hoch über dem Stausee.
Weisst du, ob dieser Dreck
den Skifellen schadet?
Nein,
nicht wenn der Dreck trocken ist.
Sonst musst du die Felle
nachher eben ein bisschen putzen.
Wir waren uns nicht sicher,
ob diese Seite des Hangs
lawingengefährdet ist.
Nein, die Nordseite ist
bis jetzt noch gut.
Ist noch gut.
Ja, es war noch recht griffig.
Die Stöcke hielten im Schnee.
Genau, man stiess nicht ins Leere.
Der 72-jährige Paul und Carmen
sind mit Bergführer Ralph Weber
derweil weiter unten
am Lac des Dix unterwegs.
Die Sonne brennt.
Carmen bereiten die Blasen
an den Füssen immer mehr Schmerzen
und noch liegen
600 m Aufstieg vor ihnen.
Die anderen Mädels tun das auch.
Die anderen Mädchen sind mir egal.
Es wird jetzt einfach etwas warm.
Aber ich denke,
das schaffen wir jetzt schon noch,
diese 600 Höhenmeter.
Ich muss
die langen Unterhosen ausziehen,
weil ich mit den langen Unterhosen
noch schlafen will.
Was hat das mit dem Schlafen zu tun?
Weil sie dann schmutzig würden.
Das ist doch egal,
das ist doch bloss Staub
und gar kein richtiger Schmutz.
Mir ist es egal,
aber es geht um die Hütte dort.
Bist du das erste Mal
auf einer Hüttentour?
Ich bin eine saubere,
anständig erzogene Toggenburgerin,
die keinen Schmutz
in fremde Häuser bringt.
Tun das Toggenburger nicht?
Toggenburger
sind also übrigens anständig.
Was soll ich jetzt tun?
Es sieht schlimm aus.
Komm jetzt!
Deine Füsse stinken etwas.
Was? Meine Füsse stinken?
So ein Quatsch!
Sicher schon!
- Nur ein wenig.
Mach jetzt vorwärts mit deinem Fuss.
Aber so stark
stinken sie doch nicht?
Ich dachte, saubere
Toggenburgerinnen stinken nicht?
Nicht, wenn wir in das Haus
anderer Leute gehen.
Ist das wirklich so bei euch?
Vielleicht hilft etwas Fusssalbe.
Auch die schnellere Gruppe
leidet unter der Frühlingshitze.
Das Ziel die Cabane des Dix
ist nach achtstündiger Skitour
immer noch nicht in Sicht.
Das Bild sagt genug.
Es wäre gelogen, zu sagen,
ich sei fit wie ein Turnschuh.
250.
Wie viel?
- 2'828.
Mach bitte keine Witze!
Nein, nein,
es sind nicht einmal 200 Höhenmeter.
Gut.
Das ist nicht gelogen.
Und schlafen werden wir heute
wie Babys,
wenn die Hütte nur auf 2'800 m ist.
Wahrscheinlich wird uns morgen
der linke Oberschenkel schmerzen.
David,
wo geht es bei diesem Felsen lang?
Rechts um die Ecke.
Gut. Und dann sieht man die Hütte?
- Ja.
Super.
Super! Sind wir bereit?
Sind wir bereit, können wir gehen.
Sind deine Füsse wieder gut?
Schmerzen deine Füsse beim Laufen?
Nein. Es ist super.
Ich spüre keinen Schmerz, nein.
So ist es richtig toll.
Auch die Oberschenkel
sind kein Thema mehr, nein.
Carmen nimmt's mit Humor.
Action!
Geradeaus - und bremsen.
Oh, Achtung!
Doch plötzlich ist
die Schneedecke unten am Stausee
voller Eisschollen und Risse,
die schwer sichtbar sind.
Paul bleibt in einer Spalte stecken.
Hier geradeaus?
Oder oben herum?
Ja, hier hat es auch eine Spalte.
- Also direkt zu dir?
Scheisse!
Dort hat es eine weitere Spalte.
Bergführer Ralph versucht,
Carmen und Paul sicher
durch die Spaltenzone zu lotsen.
Es war wie mit Kindern:
Alle 5 m fällt jemand um,
dann muss man ihm
wieder auf die Füsse helfen.
Das war die schlechteste Variante,
die wir laufen konnten.
Ach, das ist doch egal.
Ich dachte, das sei eine Abkürzung,
aber es war nun eher etwas länger.
Die anderen sind schon dort oben.
Die anderen sind dort oben, genau.
* Sphärischer Frauengesang *
Kurz vor dem Ziel und doch noch weit.
In der Ferne die Cabane des Dix.
So, die Ziellinie: flamme rouge.
Und auch Peter ist mit dabei,
er, der am Morgen
alles infrage gestellt hatte.
Ah, jetzt kann ich
den Rundblick geniessen.
Cool! Das ist zu schaffen.
Selbst Severin,
der ehemalige Zehnkämpfer, kämpft.
Eine Hütte, zu der wir
mit den Skiern fahren könnten,
das wäre doch eine gute Idee.
Es ist nicht mehr weit.
Dort oben ist sie.
Weiter unten hat Ralph
die Skis von Carmen und Paul
ein Steilstück hinauf getragen,
damit sie schneller vorwärts kommen.
So.
Suchen wir wieder einen Rhythmus.
- Ja.
Ja?
Herrlich! Ich rechnete schon
mit 600. Das sind 150 weniger.
Wie?
- Ich runde immer auf.
Endlich, nach über 9 Std.
kräftezehrender Tour,
erreicht die erste Gruppe
die Cabane des Dix.
Die armen Skifelle!
Bravo!
Gratuliere.
Wir sind alles harte Krieger.
Bravo!
Und Peter wird zum Helden.
Ich bin ziemlich am Anschlag.
Erschöpft.
Es war ein langer Weg.
Und es war heiss. Und heiss.
Du warst
mit der schnellen Gruppe unterwegs.
Aber am Schluss.
Also, es gibt definitiv eine Formel,
bei der meine Leistungsfähigkeit
mit der Aussentemperatur korreliert.
Man könnte auch noch
den Windeinfluss dazurechnen,
der mich hier hoch
in diese Hütte gerettet hat.
Und die Nähe zu Schnee
hilft auch immer.
Gleiten?
- Ja.
Severin schulde ich vier Biere,
für jedes Mal,
als Wind aufkam beim Hochlaufen.
Und ... Nein, sonst war es ...
Es dauerte länger als gedacht.
Es wollte nicht mehr aufhören.
Und dieser verdammte See.
Die ganze Zeit mussten wir
auf der linken Seite laufen.
Wenn wir auf der anderen Seite
hätten laufen müssen,
das wäre mir egal gewesen.
Im unteren Teil wussten wir
nicht genau, wo es langgeht.
So lebten wir von Kuppe zu Kuppe
und schauten voraus,
wohin uns der Weg führt.
Plötzlich waren wir im Aufstieg.
Dann wussten wir, dass es
noch etwa eineinhalb Stunden dauert.
Darauf kann man sich einstellen
und dann läuft es einfach.
Wie ein Roboter sozusagen.
Gut getapt ist auch der Zeh, den
Yolanda vor der Tour gebrochen hat.
Nun wartet sie auf ihren Vater.
Hoffentlich geht es
deinem Vater gut. - Ja.
Ich denke, in einer
dreiviertel Stunde sind sie hier.
Wenn er läuft, dann läuft er.
- Wie ein Wiesel. - Ja.
* Keuchen *
So, wie geht es?
- Ja, es geht noch.
Das ist der letzte Anstieg.
- Was?
Die letzte Kurve.
- Ja.
So weit sehe ich gerade noch.
Vor über 50 Jahren hat Paul
die Haute Route schon einmal gemacht.
So, jetzt haben wir es
bald geschafft.
Wer ist das dort? Ist das Paul?
- Ja, das dürfte mein Vater sein.
Mein Vater.
Er macht das sackstark,
in diesem Alter
noch so unterwegs zu sein.
Ja, etwas Augenpipi.
So?
Wir sind alle diese Rampe hoch.
Willst du das auch noch tun?
Gemeinsam noch einmal auf der
Haute Route - ein Traum für beide.
Zum Wohl.
- Ich bin froh um diese Pause.
Wenn ich bedenke,
dass mir 30-Jährige folgen,
bin ich voll zufrieden.
- Gratuliere. - Merci.
Nein, das war eine nahrhafte Sache.
Aber davon erholt man sich wieder.
* Jubel *
Hoppla!
- Oh, Entschuldigung.
Bravo, Paul. Was für ein Moment.
Du bist unglaublich.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Schön, bravo. Hat es geklappt?
- Ja, ja, es ist gut gegangen.
Aber der Weg dort unten rum
war die Hölle.
Das war die Bohne.
Ich bin in eine Spalte gefallen.
Ja, das waren
die Eisschollen auf dem See.
Ich kam nicht mehr raus.
- Das haben wir gesehen.
Nach über 10 Std.
erreicht auch Carmen das Ziel.
Eine Apfelschorle und keine Cola,
das ist toll.
Ist das gut?
- Das ist super.
Das können wir dir offerieren.
Magst du schon?
Nein, aber danke, danke.
Erst will man nur trinken.
(Alle) Bravo! Gratuliere!
Wir sind auch erst
vor 2 Min. angekommen.
Ja, sie haben
kaum ihre Schuhe ausgezogen.
Es war wie Eile mit Weile.
Ein Feld vorwärts
und wieder zwei Felder zurück.
* Fröhliche Handorgel-Klänge *
Die Hütte ist voll, rund 120
Tourenfahrer sind an diesem Tag
Ende April auf der Haute Route
unterwegs - von Hütte zu Hütte.
Gleichzeitig am gleichen Ort.
Noch 900 Höhenmeter fehlen.
Die morgige Etappe
beginnt in der Cabane des Dix.
Es folgt der Aufstieg
über den Col de la Serpentine
auf die Pigne d'Arolla
auf fast 4'000 m.
Dann hinunter über den Col de
l'Eveque ins Bivouac de Bouqetins.
Wieder muss die Gruppe
eine achtstündige Tour
mit über 14 km
und 1'500 Höhenmetern bewältigen.
Wir haben eine sehr schnelle
und eine schnelle Gruppe.
Das Ziel ist das Biwak Bouqetins.
* Sphärischer Frauengesang *
Start ist um 5 Uhr morgens,
der Wind hat zugelegt.
* Dramatische Klänge *
Wir steigen noch kurz hier hoch.
Die gestrige Tour
hat Spuren hinterlassen.
Carmen startet mit Schmerzen.
Ja, jetzt zieht es.
Beim Runterfahren schmerzt es.
Blasen?
- Ja, Blasen hinten am Fuss.
Blasen rund um die Ferse herum.
Hast du mehr als eine Blase?
Ja, auf beiden Seiten:
eine mehrfache Angelegenheit.
Erst war es nur eine kleine Blase
auf der einen Seite,
das ging noch.
Aber jetzt haben sich die Blasen
etwas Platz verschafft.
Kampfspuren.
Das Wetter ist noch gut, doch eine
Schlechtwetterfront wird erwartet.
Eigentlich war sie bereits
für den heutigen Tag angekündigt.
Auch Paul spürt
die Anstrengung von gestern.
Ein Teil des Gepäcks
hat ihm Severin bereits abgenommen.
Oh, die Skibindung
ist aufgesprungen, einen Augenblick.
Jawohl.
Auch Bergführer Ralph Weber hilft.
Ja, der hält.
Es ist Hochsaison
auf der Haute Route.
Mehrere Skitourengänger
aus der ganzen Welt
sind in Gruppen unterwegs,
um sich ihren Traum zu erfüllen.
Steil bergauf mit Harscheisen,
den Steighilfen an den Skiern,
geht es auf den Col de la Serpentine.
Quer durch
gewaltige Gletscherabbrüche,
über Spalten, verdeckt
vom Schnee des letzten Winters.
Hier sehen wir das Matterhorn.
Dann ein Stopp, vor dem
heikelsten Stück des Aufstiegs.
Eine kleine Pause, Sonnencreme,
Sonnenbrille, Trinken, Essen.
In fünf Minuten ziehen wir weiter.
Wir nehmen das Flachstück,
dann machen wir zwei Seilschaften:
Fünf und fünf - und dort hinten oben
wird es schön flach.
Wird es steil?
- Ja, der erste Teil geht noch,
aber wenn man um die Ecke
in die Sonne kommt,
wem dort
mit den Skiern etwas passiert,
ist schnell in Arolla unten.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Steil fällt eine Wand
aus Fels und Eis Richtung Norden ab.
Darüber der vereiste Steilhang
zur Pigne d'Arolla,
den es zu überwinden gilt.
Eine kritische Schlüsselstelle,
in der David und Ralph
als Bergführer gefordert sind.
So, Paul. Ich würde deine Skier
gerne übernehmen.
Du?
- Ja.
Yolanda wolltest du sie nicht geben,
aber ich darf sie nehmen, oder?
Na gut, ausnahmsweise.
- Ausnahmsweise? Da bin ich froh.
Du kannst sonst meine Stöcke tragen.
Zieh die Steigeisen an
und erhole dich etwas.
So kannst du etwas Kraft
für den Aufstieg sparen.
Wir brauchen noch Kraft
bis zum Bouqetin.
Das Gelände fällt ab.
Wenn jemand abrutscht,
müssen wir ihn halten können.
Kannst du fünf halten?
Ja, wenn ich aufpasse schon.
Wenn wir nahe zusammenbleiben,
schaffe ich das.
Vielleicht nicht gerade dort,
wo es senkrecht runtergeht,
aber mit dem Pickel schaffe ich das.
Und sie würde auch reagieren,
um mit dem Pickel zu bremsen.
Ist das heute
die schwierigste Passage?
Ja, ja. Das nennen sie Serpentine.
Das ist die Schlüsselstelle
für den Pigne d'Arolla.
Schaffen das alle?
- Ja.
* Majestätische Klänge *
Ralph und David
haben die Gruppe geteilt.
Am Seil und auf Steigeisen
geht es über den vereisten Schnee.
Der Wind hat zugelegt. Es ist kalt.
Vorboten der Schlechtwetterfront.
Wie nahe Leben und Tod auf einer
solchen Tour beieinander liegen,
zeigt sich zwei Tage später, als
eine andere Gruppe an dieser Stelle
in einen Sturm gerät,
die Orientierung verliert,
und sieben Personen
in der Kälte ums Leben kommen.
So schnell sich
die Verhältnisse ändern können,
so gross ist auch
die Verantwortung der Bergführer
gegenüber ihren Gästen,
die ihnen vertrauen.
Dann können wir uns
jetzt hier versammeln.
Nach dem gestrigen Tag
habe ich befürchtet,
dass es heute viel schwieriger wird,
hier hochzukommen,
aber es ging ganz gut.
Schwieriger von der Kondition her?
- Ja.
Ich konnte mich gut erholen.
Das ist sehr gut.
Es brennt einfach ein bisschen,
das merke ich.
Wenn ich in den Schuh schlüpfe,
die Skier an- und abschnalle,
schmerzt es, ja.
Aber nicht mehr so stark
wie ganz am Anfang.
Es folgen die letzten Schritte
auf die Pigne d'Arolla
mit 3'790 m dem Dach der Tour.
Bei guten Bedingungen
haben es alle geschafft,
auch Paul,
der vor 50 Jahren zum ersten Mal
genau an diesem Punkt stand.
Gratuliere.
- Gratuliere.
Gratuliere. Du bist tipptopp
gelaufen, schön regelmässig.
Das ist irrsinnig.
Ich glaubte nicht daran,
dass ich es hier hochschaffe,
aber es ist herrlich.
Also, du bist ja am Berg
mit allen Wassern gewaschen.
Ja, ich war auf vielen Gipfeln,
nicht auf allen, aber ja.
Eine Aussicht,
die für alle Strapazen entschädigt.
Doch am Horizont stauen sich bereits
die Wolken, und es ist noch weit.
Gehen wir jetzt wieder los?
- Ja.
Und endlich wieder einmal
eine Abfahrt.
* Fröhliche Handorgelklänge *
Bevor es
in die nächste Steigung geht.
Die Wolkenfront rückt immer näher.
David zieht vorne weg.
Ralph kümmert sich um Carmen.
Carmen, hast du Zeit,
um dem Wolkenspiel zuzuschauen?
Oder getraust du dich nicht mehr,
umzuschauen?
Bis du auf dem Hund?
Nein, ich laufe einfach mein Tempo.
- Das ist gut.
Geht es mit den Schmerzen?
Kann ich dir helfen? - Nein.
Soll ich vor dir laufen
und das Tempo übernehmen?
Das Tempo übernehmen?
Ich laufe vor dir und versuche,
das Tempo anzupassen.
Wir sind zügig unterwegs.
Das kommt gut.
Im Flachen schon, ja.
Nebel kommt auf, es stürmt.
Doch David kennt den Weg.
So, bravo, tipptopp.
Ist bei dir alles gut, Paul?
- Ja, ja.
Wegen dem Nebel fahren wir
jetzt schon hier Richtung Biwak.
Es folgt ein kleiner Aufstieg,
dann kommen wir gemütlich zum Biwak.
Wir müssen noch Schnee schmelzen,
damit wir Wasser fürs Kochen haben.
Es gibt noch Arbeit
heute Nachmittag.
Danke fürs Führen.
Carmen, tipptopp.
- Ja, sie macht das gut.
Ein Tick langsamer,
aber immer flüssig gelaufen.
Ich habe schwere Beine.
Die Kondition ist noch gut,
es ist mehr im Kopf:
"Du bist doch verrückt!"
Die Beine machen mit,
aber ich bin froh,
dass wir zum Ziel kommen.
Es beginnt, mich anzuöden.
Und in Gedanken war ich bereits in
der nächsten und übernächsten Woche.
Was sind die nächsten Ziele
meines neuen Geschäfts?
Wie packen wir das an?
Aber ich merkte,
dass ich abschweifte,
konnte abschalten und sagen:
"Jetzt bin ich hier."
* Dramatische Klänge *
Ihr Ziel heute
ist das Bivouac de Bouqetins,
ein Biwak,
das hoch über dem Gletscher liegt.
Es ist nicht bewirtschaftet,
verfügt aber über
eine Kochgelegenheit mit Brennholz.
Ein Platz
mitten in der Abgeschiedenheit,
weg vom Rummel der grossen Hütten.
Und nur noch einen Tag vom Ziel,
dem Matterhorn und Zermatt, entfernt.
Schau dir das an!
Das ist ja voll geil.
Cool, nicht wahr?
Ich machte mich
auf das Schlimmste gefasst,
dabei ist es so geil.
Es hat viel Platz,
sonst ist es jeweils viel enger.
Warte nur, bis alle hier sind.
Dann ist es nicht mehr so einfach,
sich hier zu bewegen.
Das sieht gut aus.
Schön.
Komm in die warme Stube.
Wir müssen wieder beginnen,
Schnee zu schmelzen für Wasser.
Ah, es hat noch ein wenig Wasser.
Wer Tee will,
wir haben Teebeutel mit dabei.
Um 18.30-19 Uhr
machen wir Tortellini.
Ich habe Jasskarten,
wenn jemand spielen will.
Entspannung
nach fünf Tagen Anstrengung.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es einen Break mit den Handy gab.
Gab es einen?
- Zuerst hatte ich keinen Empfang.
Jetzt schreibe ich kurz nach Hause,
wo wir sind.
Hast du keine Entscheidungen
getroffen, die SMS nur gelesen?
Nur gelesen, ja.
- Bravo.
Wieso liest du die SMS, wenn du
keine Entscheidungen triffst?
Dann bin ich informiert und
muss am Samstag weniger aufarbeiten.
Machst du sonst Ferien,
ohne deine SMS anzuschauen?
Aber nicht, weil ich nicht kann,
sondern weil ich nicht will.
Wenn ich eine Woche weg bin
und zwei Tage brauche, um die ange-
sammelten 350 E-Mails aufzuarbeiten,
ist der Ferieneffekt dahin.
Heute fand ich heraus, dass es
wirklich viel ... also für mich ...
Das ist jetzt
nicht so wissenschaftlich,
das betrifft nur mich.
Es ist sowohl motivierender
wie auch befriedigender für mich,
auf einen Gipfel zu steigen
als auf einen Pass.
Das finde ich noch spannend.
Heute konnte ich wirklich sagen:
Sowohl gestern Rosablanche
wie auch heute Pigne du ...
Ich habe schon wieder
den Namen vergessen.
Pigne d'Arolla
- Pigne d'Arolla - fast.
Es geht viel einfacher,
wenn ich sehe,
dass dort oben
der höchste Punkt ist,
dann kann es eh nicht weiter gehen.
Aber bei einem Pass
ist man nie sicher,
ob hinter jenem Hügel
noch ein weiterer Hügel kommt.
Es hat noch eine weitere Komponente:
Alle Menschen wollen oben sein.
Das ist doch etwas,
das uns eingepflanzt ist.
Auf einem Pass,
da bist du nicht zuoberst,
hast den Kern noch nicht erreicht.
Ich mag Pässe lieber als Gipfel.
Warum?
- Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ist mir sympathischer,
weil ich nicht gerne runter schaue.
Ja, das muss ich sagen.
Tage voller Strapazen,
die sie gefordert,
und Eindrücke, die sie geprägt haben,
liegen hinter der Gruppe.
Es brennt. Das kommt schon.
Hauswirtschaftslehrerin Yolanda
übernimmt das Kochen
gemeinsam mit Ralph.
Abgiessen?
- Warte, das mache ich.
Ich bin zuständig für diesen
blöden Griff. Geht mir aus dem Weg!
Ich giesse das heisse Wasser
wieder zurück in den Topf.
Das reicht weit.
A table, a table!
* Sie reden durcheinander *
Guten Appetit!
- Danke fürs Kochen, Yolanda.
Kurz vor dem Ziel
noch einmal ein Moment für alle,
darüber nachzudenken,
warum man sich den Traum
Haute Route erfüllen wollte.
Ich hatte
eine sehr schöne Skitourenwoche.
Ich hatte eine sehr schöne
Skitourenwoche mit euch zusammen.
Wir waren eine wunderbare Truppe.
Auch das Wetter hat mega mitgemacht,
die Landschaft war einmalig.
Das war etwas sehr Spezielles.
Die Sache mit dem Mutigwerden.
Ist das bei dir passiert?
Ein Schrittchen weit,
aber es liegt noch viel vor mir.
Ich freue mich wahnsinnig
auf meine Buben zu Hause.
Meine Mutter
schickte mir heute noch ein Foto,
wie sie am Spielen sind.
Mir kommt es vor, als wären sie
in dieser Woche enorm gewachsen.
Es sind schon wieder grössere Buben.
Es ist mir bewusst,
dass ich kaum mehr eine derart
grosse Tour mit ihr machen werde.
Wir werden wohl Tages-
oder Zweitagestouren machen,
aber sicher nicht mehr - das kann
ich mir vorstellen - eine Woche.
Ich kam bei dieser Tour
ziemlich an meine Grenzen.
Das muss ich erkennen.
Das war sehr speziell, weil es wohl
das letzte Mal gewesen sein wird,
dass wir so etwas
gemeinsam gemacht haben.
Wie mein Vater schon gesagt hat,
werden wir Tagestouren machen,
oder vielleicht Zweitagestouren
mal an einem Wochenende.
Aber eine ganze Woche,
das wird es nicht wieder geben,
auch für mich nicht.
Das war für längere Zeit
die letzte Tour.
Körperlich war es etwas anstrengend,
aber ich denke,
für den Kopf war es Gold wert.
Ich werde es
v.a. nächste Woche merken.
Im positiven oder negativen Sinn?
Nein, ich denke, ich werde
mit neuer Frische und Motivation
an etwas herangehen, über das
ich mir Gedanken machen muss
nach dieser Woche, eigentlich.
Und natürlich diese Eindrücke.
Landschaftlich war es wunderschön.
Ich musste wirklich
eine Woche lang wenig studieren.
Das war sehr erholend.
Keine unlösbaren Probleme im Kopf
zu wälzen, habe ich sehr genossen.
Ich habe auch wirklich nichts getan.
Ich dachte,
vielleicht kommt es irgendwann,
dass irgendetwas,
das mich gerade beschäftigt,
im Kopf zu drehen beginnt,
aber das war nie der Fall.
Es hat gut funktioniert.
Ich habe keine E-Mails beantwortet
und die Firma gibt es trotzdem noch.
Ich glaube, alle sind noch dort.
Und so gesehen
hat es gut funktioniert.
Es freut mich einerseits,
dass der Betrieb letztlich nicht
von einer Einzelperson abhängig ist.
Andererseits hat mich sehr gefreut,
die Haute Route
endlich einmal machen zu können,
die ich schon immer
gerne einmal machen wollte.
Das mit euch zusammen zu machen,
war super.
Du hattest verschiedene Wünsche.
Einerseits wolltest du
die Haute Route machen,
andererseits hat die Geschichte
deiner Mutter mitgeschwungen,
die Erinnerung an sie.
Wir stark war das präsent?
Ich dachte, die Erinnerungen und
alles würden wesentlich mehr sein.
Ich war ...
Ich war schlichtweg zu stark
mit mir selbst beschäftigt,
auch mit allem rundherum.
So wurde es gar
nicht zu einem Thema,
ausser auf Rosablanche, von wo ich
zwei, drei Steine mitgenommen habe,
die ich auf ihr Grab legen werde,
aber mehr nicht.
Mit welchem Gefühl
kehrst du in den Alltag zurück?
Mit welchem Gefühl?
Das kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Alles ist
so schnell vorbei gegangen.
Also, ja ... Ich hatte
viele verschiedene Eindrücke.
Ich kann es kaum genau benennen.
Vieles ist viel besser gelaufen,
als ich gedacht habe.
Ja, ich kann es
gar nicht so genau fassen.
* Sphärischer Frauengesang *
Ich merke, dass sie nach Hause will.
Und ich auch.
Noch einmal um fünf Uhr aufstehen,
noch einmal im Schein der Stirnlampen
auf dem gefrorenen Gletscher
zum letzten Aufstieg fahren.
Die letzte Etappe führt sie
vom Bivouac de Bouqetins
zum Col de la Valpelline
mit Blick aufs Matterhorn.
Darauf folgt
eine lange Abfahrt nach Zermatt,
eine Genusstour,
wenn das Wetter stimmt.
Rund 20 km und 1'500 Höhenmeter
liegen noch einmal vor ihnen.
Das ist eigentlich
der letzte Aufstieg,
bei dem wir
die Skier aufbinden müssen.
Nachher laufen und
fahren wir nur noch.
Die Haute Route ist auch
eine Geschichte über Menschen,
die an ihre Grenzen kamen.
Die lernten,
mit Steigeisen zu klettern,
sich zu überwinden und gemeinsam
als Gruppe an das Ziel zu glauben.
Das war die letzte Mauer,
jetzt folgt der Endspurt.
Hier fahren wir
200 Höhenmeter hinunter,
dann steigen wir mit den Fellen
noch 2 Std. hoch.
Und so endet dieses Abenteuer nach
sechs Tagen in den hohen Bergen
mit einem Blick aufs Matterhorn.
Erkennst du deinen Berg?
Ich war schon lange nicht mehr
so froh, diesen Hügel zu sehen.
* Jauchzer *
Daniel, ich danke dir vielmals,
äh, David, ich danke dir vielmals.
David, danke vielmals.
Das war schön.
Ja, das war so schön,
danke vielmals.
Und aus Menschen, die sich vorher
nicht gekannt haben, wurden Freunde.
Fränzi.
- Merci. Danke.
Dominique.
- David, danke vielmals. - Merci.
Super.
Daniel, danke dir vielmals.
Das war super.
Das habe ich gerne getan.
- Sicher?
In diesem Alter möchte ich
auch noch so gut laufen wie du.
Jetzt kommen mir noch die Tränen.
* Sentimentale Trompetenklänge *
Ich kann hier runterfahren, dann
bin ich zu Hause. Das ist komisch.
Nach dieser langen Strecke
plötzlich zu Hause anzukommen,
das ist verrückt.
Und dann noch aus einer Ecke,
wo ich noch gar nie war.
Auf der anderen Seite
habe ich auch schon Touren gemacht,
aber auf dieser Seite noch nie.
Das ist cool.
Und Paul
hat auch noch dafür gesorgt,
dass mir beinahe
das Augenwasser gekommen wäre.
Es ist wirklich
eine super Geschichte,
dass die beiden diese Tour
zusammen machen konnten.
Bitte, zieh die Skibrille aus.
Nein, das lassen wir jetzt.
Ich gönne ihnen von Herzen, dass sie
die Tour zusammen machen konnten.
Schön. Stimmung!
Einige wurden mutig,
andere zu Helden.
Jeder hatte sein persönliches Ziel
auf dieser Skitour des Lebens.
Denn manchmal ist es eben an
der Zeit, aus dem Alltag auszubrechen
und dem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzuzufügen.
* Majestätische Trompetenklänge *